¿qué tan grandes son?
¿Cuánto espacio es eso?
¿Cuántos servidores podrías encajar allí?
Y para algunos centros de datos,
se podrían conseguir dos de esas piezas de información.
Se sabe cuánto gastaron,
y también, por ejemplo, dado que tenían que contratar
con el gobierno local
para obtener la potencia suministrada,
se podría saber que hicieron un trato para comprar,
así que se sabe la energía que usan.
Entonces se puede ver las proporciones de esos números,
y averiguar para un centro de datos
en la que no se tiene esa información,
averiguar,
pero tal vez solo se tenga uno de esos,
digamos los metros cuadrados, entonces se puede averiguar
bueno, tal vez la potencia es proporcional.
Se puede hacer lo mismo con diferentes cantidades,
con conjeturas de la cantidad total de almacenamiento,
el número de servidores, el número de unidades por servidor,
y en cada caso usando lo que se sabe
para llegar a un modelo que reduzca
las conjeturas sobre las cosas que no se saben.
Es como girar en torno al número al que se quiere llegar.
Y es muy divertido.
La matemática no es tan avanzada,
y realmente es nada más que como
resolver un sudoku.
Así que eso hice, con toda esta información,
pasé un día o dos investigando.
Hay un par de cosas que no consideré.
Siempre se pueden ver los mensajes de reclutamiento
que Google publica.
Eso da una idea de dónde tienen personal.
A veces, cuando la gente los visita,
toma fotografías y las publica,
y se supone que no deberían de hacerlo,
pero así se puede aprender cosas sobre su hardware.
Y, de hecho, se pueden examinar los repartidores de pizza.
Resulta que ellos saben dónde están todos los centros de datos de Google,
al menos los que tienen personas en ellos.
Pero presenté mi estimación,
con la que me sentía muy bien,
que había unos 10 exabytes de datos
en todas las operaciones de Google,
y luego otros quizás 5 exabytes o así
de almacenamiento fuera de línea en cinta,
donde resulta que Google es
el consumidor más grande del mundo.
Así que presenté esta estimación, y esta es
una cantidad asombrosa de datos.
Es bastante más de lo que cualquier otra organización
tiene en el mundo, hasta donde sabemos.
Hay un par de competidores,
especialmente todo el mundo siempre piensa en la NSA.
Pero usando estos mismos métodos,
podemos mirar a los centros de datos de la NSA,
y deducir, ya saben, no sabemos lo que pasa allí,
pero está bastante claro que su funcionamiento
no es del tamaño de Google.
Sumando todo, propuse
la otra cosa que podemos responder, que es,
¿cuántas tarjetas perforadas se necesitarían?
Una tarjeta perforada puede contener
alrededor de 80 caracteres,
y pueden caber alrededor de más o menos 2000 tarjetas en una caja,
y se ponen en, digamos,
mi tierra natal, Nueva Inglaterra,
cubriría la región por completo
hasta una profundidad de un poco menos de cinco kilómetros,
casi 3 veces más profundo
que los glaciares durante la última era de hielo
hace unos 20 000 años.
Esto es poco práctico, pero creo
esa es la mejor respuesta que podía dar.
Y la publiqué en mi sitio web. Escribí al respecto.
Y no esperaba una respuesta de Google,
porque han sido tan reservados,
no respondieron a mis preguntas,
y así que solo lo puse y dije,
bueno, supongo que nunca lo sabremos.
Pero un poco más tarde
recibí un mensaje de Google,
diciendo, ey, alguien aquí tiene un sobre para usted.
Así que voy por él, lo abro,
y son tarjetas perforadas. (Risas)
Tarjetas perforadas marca Google.
Y en esas tarjetas perforadas, hay una serie de agujeros,
y dije, gracias, gracias,
bien, ¿qué hay aquí?
Conseguí un software y empecé a leerlas,
y analizarlas, y resulta
que es un rompecabezas.
Hay un montón de código,
pedí ayuda a unos amigos,
desciframos el código, y luego había otro código dentro,
y luego algunas ecuaciones,
resolvimos esas ecuaciones,
finalmente, aparece un mensaje de Google
que es su respuesta oficial a mi artículo,
y decía, "Sin comentarios".
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Me encanta calcular este tipo de cosas,
y no es que me encante hacer cálculos.
Hago mucho de matemáticas,
pero no me gustan mucho en sí mismas.
Lo que me gusta es que te permiten tomar
algunas cosas que sabes,
y solo con mover símbolos sobre un pedazo de papel,
encontrar algo que no sabías
que es sorprendente.
Recibo muchas preguntas estúpidas,
y me encanta que las matemáticas tengan el poder
para responderlas algunas veces.
Y algunas veces no.
Esta es una pregunta de un lector,
un lector anónimo,
y el asunto decía, "Urgente",
y este fue todo el email:
"Si la gente tuviera ruedas y pudiera volar,
¿cómo nos diferenciaríamos de los aviones?"
Urgente. (Risas)
Pienso que hay algunas preguntas
que las matemáticas simplemente no pueden responder.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)